- [Voiceover] The following
tables lists the values
of functions f and h,
and of their derivatives,
f prime and h prime for
x is equal to three.
So all this is telling us,
with x is equal to three,
the value of the function
is six, f of three is six,
you could view it that way.
h of three is zero, f
prime of three is six,
and h prime of three is four.
And now they want us to
evaluate the derivative
with respect to x of the
product of f of x and h of x
when x is equal to three.
One way you could view this is,
if we viewed some function,
if we viewed some function g of x.
g of x as being equal
to the product of f of x
and h of x,
this expression is the
derivative of g of x.
So we could write g prime of
x is equal to the derivative
with respect to x
of f of x
times h of x.
Which is what we see right here,
and which is what we want to
evaluate at x equals three.
So we essentially want to evaluate
g prime
of three.
This is what they're asking us to do.
Well, to do that, let's go first up here.
Let's just think about what this is doing.
They're asking us to take the derivative
with respect to x of the
product of two functions
that we have some information about.
Well, if we're taking the
derivative of the product
of two functions, you
could imagine that the
product rule could prove useful here.
So I'm just gonna
restate the product rule.
This is going to be
equal to the derivative
of the first function,
f prime of x,
times the second function,
not taking its derivative.
Plus the first function,
not taking its derivative,
f of x, times the derivative
of the second function,
h prime of x.
So if you're trying to
find g prime of three,
well that's just going to be
f prime of three times h of three
plus f of three
times h prime of three.
And lucky for us, they give
us what all these things
evaluate to.
f prime of three, right
over here, they tell us.
f prime when x is equal
to three is equal to six.
So this right over here is six.
h of three, they give us that, too.
h of three, when x is
three, the value of our
function is zero.
So this is zero.
So this first term is you
just get six times zero,
which is gonna be zero,
but we'll get to that.
Now f of three.
f of three.
Well, the function when
x is equal to three,
f of three is equal to six.
So that is six.
And then finally,
h prime evaluated at three,
h prime of x when x is equal to three,
h prime of x is equal to four.
Or you could say this is h prime of three.
So this is four.
And so there you have it.
This is going to evaluate
to six times zero,
which, that's all just gonna be zero,
plus six times four,
which is going to be equal to 24.
And we're done.